- It's time to play
Awkward Family Photos.
(applause)
Obviously, Awkward Family Photos
has made a cottage industry
out of unearthing family photos
that should have remained
repressed in people's memories.
But for 250 points I
want you to caption
these family
delightful photographs.
First up, these
very close siblings.
(bell chime)
Yes, Blaine.
- Dad says we're not allowed
to talk to the press.
(applause)
- Points.
Uh, Drew.
- That's Bonnie and Clyde
and some kid they're fucking.
(laughter)
(applause)
- It was the thirties, things
were different then, come on.
Points, Brendon.
- Shirtless kids leave
behind mysterious photo
before committing
suicide by cop.
(groans)
(applause)
- Oh, oh, they came
back around, okay.
Okay, you got points,
they came back around.
Next one up, this
college brochure.
Yep.
(laughter)
(bell chime)
I am not related to
these earthlings.
Drew.
- It's pronounced Gor-don.
(laughter)
- Points.
They just have a...
They're just housing a
foreign exchange student.
One here and one
from another galaxy.
Yes, Brendon.
- Yes, we adopted
Bak-soon from Korea
and Lothar the Destroyer of
Men from 13th century Romania.
- Points, good, good.
(applause)
Next up, this crawl
space decoration.
(groans)
(bell chime)
Brendon.
- Joan Wayne Gacy, right?
- Oh, nice, points.
(applause)
Drew.
- Hey, guess how many kids I
have buried in my backyard.
(laughter)
- Points.
Blaine.
- While I drink this glass
of water, Raggedy Anus
will tell you that I am a
registered sex offender.
(laughter)
- That had a whole narrative.
- I'm gonna show you on the doll
where I want you to touch me.
(laughter)
- Come with me if
you want to live.
- Points to Blaine,
all right, next.
These tatted bros,
these tatted up bros.
(bell chime)
- [Drew] Whoa, whoa,
whoa, that's from
my personal fucking
computer, you cocksuckers.
(applause)
- You shouldn't sign
onto an open network,
this is what happens.
- I leave my computer
alone for five minutes,
I'm a guest here.
- Always sign into
a secure network.
This is what happens
Drew, Blaine.
- It's weird that they're
holding the auditions
for the new Twilight
movie in this van.
(laughter)
- Points.
Yeah, Brendon.
- Hey, pussy, I
dare you to kiss me.
(laughter)
- Points.
All right, last one,
this festive family.
This festive family.
(bell chime)
Yes, Blaine.
- All those things
go in the dog.
(groans)
(applause)
- [Chris] Points, Drew.
- The aristocrats.
- [Chris] The aristocrats,
yeah, perfect.
Well done, boys, well done.
- Beautiful, beautiful.
- Yeah, Brendon.
- Cheers is filmed in front
of a live studio audience.
(laughter)
- Points.
That guy looks like
Dr. Demento though.
- He does, and the kid
looks like Nosferatu.